heuer nehmen rund 15.000 soldatinnen und
soldaten aus 30 nationen an der
internationalen soldatenwallfahrt nach
lourdes österreich ist mit 500 soldaten
und zivilbediensteten vertretend vom 17
23 mai steht das gemeinsame gebet und in
frieden im zentrum des treffens die
soldatenwallfahrt ist die größte für die
kundgebung von soldatinnen und soldaten
der europäischen armeen höhepunkt für
jeden wallfahrer ist der besuch der
erscheinungs gold mit dem als
wunderpferd geltenden quellwasser
bundesminister rossi nimmt an der
soldatenwallfahrt teil und besucht die
soldaten im zeltlager der anschließende
empfang gibt ihm die möglichkeit zum
gespräch mit den soldaten militär
bedeutet auch das militär musikkapellen
aufspielen auf allen straßen und plätzen
der stadt wird musiziert
die militärmusik niederösterreich
begeisterten mit ihren darbietungen
[Applaus]